well well well look who it is  it's your old pal vogue back again gotta  stop at night okay so here's the thing I  want to make another SC p video and this  time I'm gonna be taking suggestions  through my Facebook page so if you  wouldn't mind hopping over to my  facebook page link in the description  you can go over and vote on what you  would like to see or hear probably hear  most likely here as I make audio  adaptations so um if you could see what  I was doing that would be confusing to  me as I anyway so sorry  so if this video serves no other purpose  then than to do that if you make  suggestions underneath this video they  won't work it'll be like putting mal in  a microwave won't work it'll probably no  okay so that's that that's all really if  you do that that will be good that'll be  good doing don't you do it Volgin says  alright through it he says okay no but  now by I see you later okay ma yeah I'll  give you a hug you know I